وكانت النتائج النهائيه للانتخابات
البرلمانيه في اسرائيل اظهرت سيطرت معسكر
رئيس الوزراء السابق بنيامين الثانياهو
على 64 من مقاعد الكنيست المئه والعشرين
ما يخوله لتشكيل حكومه جديده تساوت مقاعد
الكود مع ما حصلت عليه الاحزاب الدينيه
والحريديه بحصول كل فريق على 32 مقعدا
ابرز الاحزاب المرشحه لدخول الحكومه
الجديده في اسرائيل تحالف الصهيونيه
الدينيه التي حصل على 14 مقعدا وهو مؤلف
من حزبين يمينيين متشددين هما القوه
اليهوديه برئاسه بني كثير والصهيونات
الدينيه برئاسه
ايضا حزب شاس للمتدينين الشرقيين وقد حصل
على 11 مقعدا وكذلك حزب يهودات وهو من
الاحزاب الحديديه التي تعتبر مظله سياسيه
لليهود
المتدينين الغربيين وقد حصل على سبعه
مقاعد